hi in this video we are going to talk
about prokaryotic versus eukaryotic
replication machinery and our point of
difference is based on which type of
enzymes is used in prokaryote versus new
carriers so let's begin in case of
prokaryotes since there is no nucleus
the replication starts in the origin of
replication site and the replication
bubble is expanded in the both sides and
that is how the replication process
takes place inside the bacteria so let's
look at one side of the replication fork
as shown here so the first thing which
is required for the replication is a
helices enzyme because these chromosomal
DNA are pretty much intertwined so the
it has to be relaxed tuple logically and
helices does those job it helps to
unwind the DNA and release the single
strand from the double stranded
configuration now then guy raised is
another important enzyme in this process
but the crucial ones are prime is prime
is begins the process of replication
extension by synthesizing small primers
because replication cannot take place
without the help of a primer the
polymerase enzyme can only extend a
short primer the primer synthesis
reaction takes place with the help of
primers enzyme so it's crucial for the
beginning of the replication after that
there are single strand binding protein
the single strand binding protein binds
to the single strand which are like now
unwind with the help of helices they
keep the strands in an relaxed situation
or the prevents tan to intertwine with
each other and that is the important
function of single stranded binding
protein
now the key polymerize enzyme is
actually the complex of paul 3 and it
has also bitter clamp and a clamp loader
complex in a moment it would be clear
how it is functioning but the overall
function of this polymerase 3 is
extending the 3 prime end of the primer
which is synthesized by Primus so the
primer synthesis reaction takes place
differently for two different strands
one strand as you can see here this
synthesis takes place pretty continuous
it is called the leading strand strand
in the other case the synthesis is
discontinuous and takes place in several
phases or in turns so this second strand
is known as the lagging strand and the
lagging strand replication is big
different from the leading strand now
let's look at the progression of the
polymerase and try to understand how it
is synthesizing so when the polymerase
is moving from five prime to three prime
end it is synthesizing or adding new
dntps at the end of these growing strand
but the problem is without the help of
any guidance it would fall off after
synthesizing certain lengths so the
process if 'ti of the R&A process is VT
of the DNA paltry would be very very low
in that situation another important
complex which is known as the bitter
clamp and which is loaded in turn by the
clamp loader is actually pretty helpful
because the beta clamp ensures that the
process of VD of the enzyme is pretty
high and it can really process a lot at
one time that means it can really help
in extension or polymerization reaction
for a long stretch of time and with high
level of proofreading now let's look at
eukaryotic cells and try to appreciate
the differences between a prokaryotic
and eukaryotic replication machinery so
in case of eukaryotes there are multiple
sites of origin so there are a multiple
origin of replication and each of these
origin of replication is expanding in
two direction and the bubble is formed
and which is moving in two direction so
let's look at one side and in this
situation as well we have two poi
summarize which take care about the
topology of these DNA and make sure it
does not intertwine it to each other
there are pol alpha which is very
similar to the Primus enzyme presenting
the prokaryotes pol alphas job is to
form primers and these primers would
actually be a
actually be the nucleating factor on
which the RNA polymerase on which the
DNA polymerase sorry for that on which
the DNA polymerase is actually expanding
so the RPF proteins are pretty
equivalent to the single cell single
strand binding protein and here the
polymers is also different key
polymerizes which are taking part in
expanding or extension stiff are the DNA
Paul tell te' and DNA pol epsilon in
case of eukaryotes there isn't the beta
clamp is actually known as PCNA it's
just the same type of machinery but with
a different name and there is also a
lagging strand and leading strand
mechanism and the leading strand
synthesis takes place smoothly whereas
lagging 10 strands synthesis takes place
in steps or I would say in phases so
that is the similarity between
eukaryotic and prokaryotic replication
but the big diversity comes from the
type of enzymes which are used in two of
these cases actually in eukaryotes there
are a lot of variety of polymerizes and
there are different polymerizes for
mitochondrial DNA replication as going
but about which I'm not going to discuss
in this video there would be a different
video about that so if you liked this
video give me a thumbs up it was a quick
introduction video about that so given
comes up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you